in other world news dozens of rohingya
refugees feared drowned while trying to
swim to malaysian shores
have been found alive the coast guard
says they were hiding in bushes on a
small island
all have been detained as malaysia does
not recognize refugee status
more than 700 000 rohingya fled myanmar
after a military crackdown in 2017
most are living in camps in bangladesh
let's get more from florence lui who's
in kuala lumpur forest
florence so a lucky escape for these
refugees tell us about what happened and
how they were found
well yes so initially they were thought
to have drowned because only one person
from that group made it to shore on
saturday night and he was detained by
police and authorities launched a search
and rescue operation on saturday evening
and into sunday as well
but now authorities say that the rest of
the group 26 of them
were found hiding in bushes on an eyelet
just off
langkawi island in the north west of
peninsula malaysia
and they were found late on sunday now
in addition to the 26 people who were
found
there was also another man who was
rescued by fishermen
at sea now authorities say they have
detained all
27 of them and 28 including the man who
made it to shore on saturday night
now a senior coast guard official told
reuters news agency
that these people nearly 30 of them are
believed to have been smuggled into the
country
on a smaller boat and he believed that
they
likely traveled to malaysia on a bigger
ship
from bangladesh as ship that could carry
about hundreds of
other rohingya refugees now these men
have now these people have now been
detained they include
men women and children they've been
detained in addition authorities say
they've also arrested two
other rohingya who are suspected of
being involved in the
trafficking or people smuggling off this
group of people into
malaysia now malaysia as a country does
not recognize refugees so it means that
those who make it here don't have any
legal status they can't work
they can't send their children to school
but malaysia is still considered a
favorite destination a sort of safe
haven
because it's a muslim-majority country
and
the mainly muslim rohingya feel safe
here despite not having any legal status
but that is slowly changing
now last month malaysian authorities
detained nearly 270
rohingya rohingya refugees they were
found to vent at the country
their boat was damaged malaysia in the
past has sent rohingya refugees back
out to sea but the authorities say they
couldn't do so because this boat was
damaged
now the prime minister has said malaysia
is no longer able to accept any more
refugees it's already struggling to cope
with an economy that's been battered by
the pandemic
thank you very much for that florence
louis live for us in
kuala lumpur